seht ihr dieses licht was von der seite
kommt hallo das ist wieder einmal waren
und wir kamen zu einem neuen food test
test video war toll und es ist geil ich
weg leute
wir brauchen ein büro hatten sie doch
mal waren willkommen zu einem neuen text
video heute werden wir vegas fastfood
testen wir waren ja letztens erst
unterwegs um bei betis in berlin zu
testen aber da es jetzt gerade so kalt
ist und regnerisch dachten wir bleiben
wir lieber zu hause und bestellen
wo sich das gut
wir haben bei konventionellen fast food
restaurants wie mcdonald's bestellt aber
auch bei veganen fast food restaurants
und wollten einfach mal gucken wer
bietet was an und was gibt es eigentlich
so in veganen fast food bereich unser
erster kandidat ist
wir haben das bett liegend ts menü
bestellt mit dem weg gegen ts und noch
mal zum mitschreiben dass es hier keine
werbung ich wurde von keinem laden
bezahlt ich stehe mit keinem laden in
kontakt dass es einfach nur meine eigene
meinung und ein testvideo also werden
natürlich firmennamen genannt aber das
kommt alles von mir und kann
ich finde das natürlich nicht könig don
ist es scheiße zu unserer bestellung gab
es einmal socken zum menü gibt es eine
große pommes dies natürlich wie kann ein
getränk und natürlich mcdonald's typisch
wir haben cach abriss zwiebeln normale
zwiebeln gewürzgurken und bürger sind
gar nicht so schlecht aus muss man sein
also optisch und so sieht der bürger von
innen aus zumal google brust der toten
wird der bürger damit sonst besteht und
der partie des big wgt es besteht aus zu
während weizen hergestellt wird doch
anders vermarkten gummi der zuschläge
wird wieso zwei erzfeinde sie sich so
zusammen tun wir gerade gehört habt der
bürger partie wird von meßlinger
gestellt also moralisch kann man hier
sagen absolute niete geschmacklich okay
was sagst du zu den promis ein bisschen
lassen
anni hat man bauschmerzen von dem lokal
bei den sensiblen magen habt es muss man
auch sagen wir haben natürlich perfekt
bestellt und so getaktet das wird wieder
ein bisschen warten müssen und dann
kommt die nächste lieferung kann
bestimmt in 321 koch so kleine [ __ ]
guck mal da ich wir machen weiter mit
wenn dann wenn dann plant burger ich
glaube beim anderen ihnen nagen schon
mal richtig gut aus sie haben wir die
chili cheese freinberger der
cheeseburger
sie haben uns oreo kekse was sind ihre
heute alles oft geschenke machen wir
fangen mal ganz gelegen hier mit den
chili cheese freis anlauf zwiebeln sind
da drauf haller peñoles und eine käse
schmeckt lecker schmecken und mein gott
war mit damit stimmt allerdings so krass
ab gerade also gut brauchen denn kommen
können tierhalter pennies essen
ich muss sagen die nagels sehen sehr gut
aus
dazu probleme mit veganem einem lese süß
sauer so ist es natürlich auch lecker
von einem
anderen laden den wir jetzt hier nicht
namentlich nennen aber nicht richtig
freuen
was ist denn das hier schwimmen
commission hat ohne hammer wo liegen die
preislich nagel 24 euro das ist ein mann
geht ein euro 1 euro ist schon kart chor
dann überlegst was du dafür früher ein
cheeseburger bekommen hast jetzt kommt
aber wirklich an das eingemachte ihr
könnt mir nicht erzählen dass das nicht
das schönste ist was ihr jemals in
meinem leben gesehen habe punkt nummer 1
es ist ein brötchen in diesem haus
lieben wir brüder sprüchen jetzt wollen
wir mal schauen wie sie von innen
aussieht
wir haben hier drauf tomate gewürzgurken
salat rote zwiebeln käse sehr wichtig
burger soße ja und dieses helle petty
und widersprüchen also guten appetit
leute ich bin gespannt
oh mein gott das ist der beste weg eine
burger dem leben
wir haben natürlich mal versucht die
bestseller zu bestellen damit wir
wirklich sehr wild eagle schmecken sie
habe auch noch einen schicken burger
ich hoffe wenn der nicht nur die
schicken nagels drauf
das kann man doch niemand ist das vegan
ist so mit chicken bürger überrascht und
mit einer mario soße und gurken
let's go leute also ich mache alles was
frittiert das ist ja super lecker aber
ich persönlich bin ich kein fan von so
großen bogen stücken den bürgern durch
mit dem metallisch der bürger war schon
ganz gut aber leute ich sag euch mal was
der cheeseburger die qualität preis und
die nuggets waren macht der chicken
bürger ja ok hmm
kommen wir zu unserem dritten und
letzten lieferservice für heute.de
medien und wird aliens street food ist
dass die falafel pitzer was ich hab ihr
sehen könnt hier ist falafel als waffe
gemacht eine verlaufe war für dringen
heißt macht freddy auf jeden fall mit
und gebratenes gemüse darauf eigentlich
auch wieder folge ist eine pizza ist es
eine falafel ist es eine falafel waffe
wir wissen es nicht
die idee ist gut und ich glaube es
frisch im laden schmeckt auch super aber
bestellt ist ist nicht der hit das ist
einfach ein hotdog das finde ich mega
interessant der ist auch mit gurke und
röstzwiebeln und soße belegt wie halt
ein normaler hot dog wir schneiden mal
auf es ist jetzt halt nicht der coole
crazy gelb-rote hot dog den man
irgendwie von ikea kennt aber bestimmt
wird er geschmacklich überzeugen
nein nicht viel zu trocken ist weil
verlassen schon sehr trocken mir fehlt
da zb ketchup drauf es ist eine
alternative für einen echten hot dog
nein ist es eine crazy coole art
verlassen zu essen ja
man bringe mir nein spaß das ist der
brawn gp hat los und was gab es da habe
ich als geschenk
das macht auch mittlerweile kein gutes
gefühl mehr wenn man sowas geliefert
bekommt dann denkt man sich gleich ich
bin der größte den es auf dieser welt
gibt ich bin jetzt wirkt auf jeden fall
wie coole streetfood an spa und wenn du
dein essen verprügeln kannst ist es zu
hart
im preis sind überhaupt nicht überhaupt
noch appetit omega petit schwanger bin
mir nicht so sicher was ich glaube wenn
man sich das frisch auf der straße holt
also so wie street view gemacht ist
könnte es vielleicht sogar besser sein
aber es ist sehr hell wie wir mal so
viele dinge geschenkt gekriegt das ist
schön
leute es ist tag nummer zwei und auch
wenn es vielleicht nicht glauben könnt
ich habe wieder hunger wir fangen mit
der dom - veganen pizza an
ich kenne dominus noch von ganz ganz
früher aus dänemark damals hatten sie
einen richtig geilen panierten pizzateig
könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern
ich weiß nicht warum der jetzt nicht
mehr so ist wie früher aber der war
damals so geil aber jetzt gibt es eben
panierten pizzateig sondern um die
vegane sieht ein bisschen trocken aus
ihr könnt euch ja mal selber ein bild
davon machen hier oben an der ecke kann
man auf jeden fall sehen dass da soße
fehlt bei dominus gibt es ja so
vorgefertigte vorn dann wird da eine
kelle tomaten so das ist alles sehr
abgerechnet und es wird so gemacht wie
es quasi jeder dominus martin tollen
pizzateig haben sie definitiv nicht mehr
das ist relativ traurig wie das aussieht
das ist sieht nicht mehr aus als ob sie
einem steinofen gebacken
ich mag aber pizza mit tomaten
champignons und broccoli die belegung
hier auf dieser seite für mich extrem
gut guten appetit teams heute reden wir
mal über die frische der zutaten das
hightech anne ja gebraucht aber wir
finden nichts also die zutaten sehen
frisch aus was ja so eine vegane pizza
schaffen sollte deshalb den käse zu
ersetzen und zu sagen hey diese pizza es
wieder einmal was muss sonst auf einer
pizza tierisch sein okay unsere nächste
bestellung ist mexikanisch glaube der
lahn ist nicht so gut er wurde nicht so
gut bewertet jetzt gibt es natürlich wie
toast akustisch erzählen dass es keine
echte das ist echter käse das ist doch
echter käse vom look her sieht es jetzt
nicht so appetitlich aus aber der geruch
ist sehr gut der kaeser sieht aus wie
original weselsky passe dass der laden
kümmern auch saufen geht das schmeckt
wie käse kann zumindest sehen das ist
käse nicht weil die haben auch einen mit
käse untersteht nicht gegangen da steht
vegan
das muss weh getan sein wir machen
weiter mit ich kann die dreieinhalb
sterne auch irgendwo verstehen besser
welt und ist der monitor sie doch saftig
aus riecht auch sehr lecker aber
passiert wenn nicht so viel drin das
sieht aus als ob das nur reis und ob ich
sehe dann ist sie die erste blauen
schlau erreichen müssen hart das ist in
ordnung aber es ist ja dreieinhalb
sterne zu setzen sollen nett sein aber
das ist irgendwie wb einfach also ich
glaube es gibt definitiv bessere muss
man meine hände marke sachen die
gefriertruhe deswegen gibt's müssen hier
davon geräusche ich habe aber hunger
machen weiter weiß woran ich das
erinnert an diese mikrowellen gerichte
die du so bekommt und diese so ähnlich
ist das auch einfach sprechen macht
wieder daran anime kugeln wir haben hier
unseren tag auflagen und daraus machen
wir jetzt unseren eigenen york wenta
kentucky scheint eigentlich härter
das von den boden das ist die kommune
die sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
also die zutaten für mich eigentlich
alles super aber ich finde der riecht
nach irgendwas was nach schuhe oder noch
lena ja gut ich meinen geschmack muss
überzeugen nicht der geruch ist ja bei
der jackpot genauso guten appetit
[Musik]
minute auch ganz ehrlich ich werde jetzt
auch hier mal meine meinung sagen
beilagen toppings wie man es auch nennt
super das brot ist eklig ich finde es
eklig ich weiß nicht was es art von brot
ist es schmeckt und riecht da hat er
noch nie mit schwickert irgendwas was
ich irgendwann mal ist es die pasta
dieser laden wo man sich so zum
cocktails trinken trifft sausalitos ja
ich nur sagen dass keeper ist jetzt zeit
nicht so meine ich will veganer essen
ich werde mir jetzt mal was geiles
bestellen und damit kommen wir zum
letzten test für dieses video und zwar
gibt es vietnamesisch asiatisch wir
zeigen euch die realität wir müssen es
nicht schön reden
oh mein gott das ist für drei sachen der
nächste laden heißt pappano und ist
sushi vegan asiatisch wir haben hier
einmal sushi in einem teigmantel vegane
sagte spieße mit erdnusssoße wochen noch
mehr verpacken entenbrust vegan ich pack
das ist nicht aus der tüte raus damit
das halt die sauce mit heute ein video
gesehen von jemandem der weizen gluten
fleisch selber gemacht hat
von der konsistenz find ich cool es
erinnert an münchen oder entenfleisch
geschmack nicht hinten gleich ich bin
glaube ich habe mich das echt also klar
ist ansonsten bin ich auf dieser seite
spielte spannend so sieht's aus meine
damen und herren ich finde hier die
konsistenz halt ersten töne soja steht
so und als letztes und darüber wie ich
mich am meisten freue ist tatsächlich
das sushi also ihr kennt natürlich alle
irgendwas stücke das hier einfach nur
ein bisschen plastik uns zu trennen eine
wiese eine frittierte sushi rolle die
antwort zu sushi aus dem westen zum
letzten mal 100 benutzer geht das hier
messen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
positiv überrascht von den meisten
gerichten weil ich oft schon vegetarisch
bestelle aber jetzt manchmal nicht so
lust auf veganer weil ich mir denke es
ist aber nicht so geil wie vegetarisch
gestern die bürger waren richtig richtig
lecker
was mir besonders bei den bestellungen
aufgefallen ist das egal ob vegan oder
nicht vegan restaurants sehr von der
qualität sich auch unterscheiden können
gerade wenn man glaube ich die ersten
veganen sachen mal ausprobieren und
bestellen möchte sollte man sich
wirklich gute leben dafür aussuchen
damit man merkt was vegan alles kann und
wie gut vegan auch schmecken kann so was
wie ein bürger oder eine pizza und das
ist mein wort zum sonntag
es war sehr lecker hat mir gerne in die
kommentare was für food existieren noch
sehen wollt vielleicht auch mal wieder
eins wo wir unterwegs sein können wenn
das wetter ein bisschen besser wird
ansonsten findet ihr hier ein arzt
mehrkanal dort einen gaming kanal
hier könnt ihr meinen kanal abonnieren
und dort gibt es ein weiteres video bis
zum nächsten mal leute da und denkt dran
ich habe auch instagram tik tok nicht
mehr ganz so